à présent une nouvelle revendication à
barmouth le groupe paramilitaire rose
Wagner annonce avoir pris le contrôle de
la mairie de la ville on aperçoit vous
allez le voir sur les images le chef de
Wagner
Prigogine brandissante un drapeau russe
des images sont accompagnées d'un
message au sens légal darkmouth a été
capturé dit-il on retrouve tout de suite
ne correspondant à Kiev biodivers crack
bonjour univer les crèmes de son côté
assurent qu'elle tient ton corps cette
localité objet ces dernières semaines
rappelons-le de déclaration
contradictoires
pas tout à fait contradictoire en
réalité puisque ce que les Ukrainiens
ont dit c'est que il continue de tenir
le centre ville de batmouth mais ils ne
font pas explicitement mention de la
mairie je pense que si ce n'était pas
vrai que les Russes avaient pris le
contrôle de la mairie l'état majorité
aurait explicitement un nier c'est
déclarations ce qu'il dit c'est qu'ils
vont continuer la lutte et il y a une
grande partie du centre-ville qui est
encore
occupée par les forces ukrainiennes il
admettent ni ni avoir perdu le contrôle
de la mairie ce qui connaissent bien la
géographie de backmouth estime que cette
vidéo où l'on voit que ni Prigogine et
crédible à juger de ce qu'on voit
derrière lui dans le fond après je pense
que le contrôle légal de la ville pour
avoir ici le drapeau russe sur la mairie
du point de vue juridique cela ne veut
rien dire évidemment puisque cette
mairie bien sûr ne fonctionne pas depuis
plusieurs mois comme tout le centre
ville de backmouth elle est très
sévèrement endommagée par les combats
merci beaucoup Gulliver Craig en direct
de Kiev pour France